[Musica]
popolo di striscia
se lo dico subito no perchè se no poi
uno dice non sono io è anche senza
giacca verde sono sempre luca guardate
alla televisione mi fa piacere grazie di
cuore
allora ragazzi sono qui perché ho da
dire una cosa importantissima in italia
si può fare carriera anche senza
raccomandazione o rubato che la faccia e
vero io per esempio sono dal 2005 nel
programma più seguito della tv italiana
e pensateci sono arrivato senza l'aiuto
di un politico senza avere un parente
potente ci sono arrivato senza dare il
mio corpo in cambio di successo anche
perché o col corpo che mi ritrovo
ragazzi sarebbe stato troppo facile
quando facevo studenti a 20 anni
studiava architettura e ho pensato che
potesse essere una cosa carina
cominciare a guadagnare qualche soldino
facendo l'animatore ecco ora non fate
quelle facce no perché lui lo sta sta
già pensando
abete giovani abbronzato fresco nei
villaggi camicia hawaiana rimorchi alle
turiste
no io facevo l'animatore ai matrimoni
napoletani sequestri di persona che
cominciano a mezzogiorno e finiscono a
mezzanotte che quando pensi che tutto
sia finito
esci ti danno la bomboniera e trovi
un'insalatiera gigante grande quanto una
jacuzzi vino agli spaghetti e vongole
per ricominciare
in sostanza io ero il domatore di
piccoli guerrieri lanciatori di
cotolette patatine fritte
io facevo un lavoro umile però capì
subito una cosa una cosa che mi ha
aiutato tantissimo
secondo me al mondo non esistono lavori
umili ma esistono modi umili di fare i
lavori cioè mi spiego io quando andavo
lì ero nel ristorante caso gennarino a
mare però mi sentivo come se fosse una
star come se fossi fiorello
uno show del sabato sera cioè io pensavo
ok sono pagato per fare una cosa la
voglio fare bene
pensai se una festa destra più bella del
mondo se c'è un festeggiato dobbiamo
festeggiarlo davvero in sostanza non
stiamo facendo nulla di strano stava
semplicemente facendo le cose per bene e
facendo le cose per bene ho capito che
veramente si poteva ottenere tanto
perché nel giro di poco divenire
animatore più richiesto e comincia a
guadagnare molto di più dei miei
colleghi capite l'importanza di fare le
cose per bene che mondo sarebbe se tutti
cominciassero a fare le cose per bene o
ci sarebbe più striscia la notizia no
però oltre questo capi un'altra cosa
importante che è fondamentale
importantissimo può essere molto utile
per affermare la propria fortuna
sperimentarsi costantemente ecco la
sperimentazione ci aiuta tantissimo gli
esperti quelle che saranno molto più di
me ma molti quello sapranno dicono che
ognuno di noi ha un'aria di confort una
comfort zone all'interno della quale si
muove con disinvoltura cercando di
ripetere delle azioni consuete
collaudate evitando così le brutte
figure ecco io ho capito questo sapete
quando quando per la prima volta dopo
aver fatto per tanti anni animatore
comincia a fare il clown la mia prima
volta da clown mi ha illuminato mi
chiamarono dall'agenzia per la quale
lavoravo mi dissero luca senti abbiamo
un problema abbiamo il clown che domani
in uno spettacolo e si è ammalato ed il
suo chiamato un medico che chiamate me
no no no luca dovesse sostituirlo io
creda nello scandalo ma come siete pazzi
io il cloud non lo farò mai mi fate fare
una figuraccia poi insomma loro hanno
insistito io così ho voluto accontentare
e in meno di 24 ore
ho imparato a truccarmi ho imparato a
vestirmi da clown ho preso una valigia
che mi hanno dato
ho messo su quattro gag e sono andata a
fare lo spettacolo
oggi il numero di battaglia e non ci
ferma nessuno
nullo di quella sera fu non rideva
nessuno
no mamma ragazzi una tragedia atomica
atomica una figura marroncina di quelle
memorabili ragazzi però io sapete cosa
fece lì bisognava soltanto battere
ritirate rinunciare per sempre
invece io ho pensato ma bravi non si
nasce
bravi si diventa allora vuoi vedere che
forse si riesca anch'io ma se lo fanno
loro perché non posso farlo anch'io ne
organizza i provare a migliorare
feci qualche prova e nel giro di un po
di tempo sono diventato un clown
richiesto ho cominciato a lavorare meno
perché lo spettacolo di corner un'oretta
e poi a guadagnare di più
capite se mi fossi fermato quella volta
che avevo fatto la mia figuraccia
all'esordio
ecco se mi fossi fermato lì non sarebbe
arrivata striscia e probabilmente oggi
non sarei qui e a proposito di striscia
la mia prima volta striscia mi ha dato
una delle lezioni più belle che la vita
mi potesse insegnare era l'otto gennaio
2005 e andré non del mio servizio che
era inserito nel concorso per la ricerca
dei nuovi inviati in sostanza da ad un
servizio e doveva cercare di raggiungere
più voti degli altri per farmi diventare
inviato e quel giorno ragazzo ho capito
una cosa veramente potentissima
in sostanza che avevo bisogno di un
comitato elettorale che si mettessero lì
a cliccare a darmi tanti voti ma non ce
ne fu bisogno perché per tanti anni
avevo lavorato cercando di dare il
meglio di me facendo le cose per bene e
mi sono ritrovato che tutti quelli che
mi avevano conosciuto tutte le famiglie
dei bambini
tutte le persone che avevano apprezzato
la mia generosità la mia precisione il
mio voler fare le cose per bene
erano pronti a votarmi e stavano facendo
votare tutte le loro famiglie
e in sostanza il mio sogno era diventato
il loro io questa cosa se avete uno
chiamato l'ho chiamata legge del clown
legge del clown perché in sostanza il
clown chi è
è uno che dà senza voler nulla in cambio
ti da dieci minuti di risate ma non è
che ti chiede indietro ma quando mi
ridai questi dieci minuti che ti ho dato
ecco il clown riesce a darci una lezione
importante io facendo le cose per bene
avevo ottenuto delle cose che non mi
aspettavo
semplicemente perché ero disinteressato
e noi molto spesso sbagliamo
perché quando diamo ad avere
un'aspettativa che ci frega
inevitabilmente perché perché non esiste
un'unità di misura per pesare ciò che
diamo è ciò che riceviamo cioè quello
che per me può avere un valore per te
può non averlo quello che magari non
avere per me insomma vale il discorso
anche al contrario allora il segreto è
uno
eliminiamo l'aspettativa facciamo come
fa il clown da senza voler nulla in
cambio
e guardate che dare non è che vuol dire
per forza regalare cose costose robe
impegnativa dare e anche semplicemente
dare ascolto dare può essere un sorriso
una pacca sulla spalla può essere che ne
so veramente per riuscire a dare
qualcosina di piccolo di semplice che
può far stare meglio il prossimo
e allora vicino avete tante persone non
lo so magari che avete vicino non riceve
un abbraccio da tempo e allora un
abbraccio quanto ci costa ci costa zero
allora possiamo abbracciarci già da oggi
io vi invito a farlo adesso
abbracciatevi fatelo fatelo anche se non
vi conoscete e bellissimo abbracciarvi
guardate come siete belli quando vi
abbracciate siete stupendi bellissimi e
sorridenti vive il popolo lidl dix che
si abbraccia bravi così
attenzione che l'ultima volta che ho
fatto sta cosa sono scomparsi portafogli
nelle tasche no no veramente fate
attenzione non è colpa mia si sviluppa
di portafogli però lo so ci sono sempre
gli scettici c'è qualcuno diceva bene
luca peraltro di cito sitter che tutto
ti va bene tu sei una persona
soddisfatta per sono appagata a me le
cose vanno male tu non hai i problemi
che ho io
ecco ragazzi allora chiariamo anche
quest'altra cosa il mondo non è fatto da
persone che hanno i problemi e persone
che i problemi non ce ne hanno il mondo
è fatto da persone che hanno i problemi
e decidono di incupirsi e farli
diventare dei drammi delle tragedie e
persone che i problemi ce li hanno
e decidono comunque di isolarli e
continuare a onorare la fortuna che
abbiamo a vivere la vita
e sappiate che coloro che si incupiscono
e vedono tutto negativo sicuramente
attrarranno negatività mentre invece mi
piace pensare che si sta una legge che
dice che sorriso chiama sorriso
positività richiama positività e quindi
un esperimento che sulla mia pelle che
ha funzionato finora
infine io mi auguro che ognuno di voi
abbia un sogno
se non ce l'avete da tra comprato pure
su internet lo trovate meno di te ma
soprattutto mi auguro e questo è
l'augurio vero che ho è che ognuno di
questi ha pronto ad inseguirlo e badate
bene ho detto inseguirlo no perché c'è
gente che il sogno lo aspetta come se
fosse che sono autobus che passa la
ferma alla fermata
no non è così allora i sogni sono dei
treni in corsa i sogni passano e noi
dobbiamo allenarci tutti i giorni a ad
essere veloci a calibrare il tentativo
di salto a provare a imparare ad
aggrapparmi a rimanerci sopra anche
quando sembra che questo treno sia più
veloce
e più difficile da da montare
ecco è così che si fa allora questo può
essere un segreto per essere essere
pronti a salire su questo treno e
sappiate che si può cadere da questo
treno ma ogni caduta non sarà un vostro
fallimento sarà soltanto un allenamento
in più che sarà utilissimo per saltare
su quello successivo
e magari una volta sopra vi direte o
meno male che ho beccato il secondo il
primo non era un granché non era proprio
come questo
quindi mi piace vederla così e quindi
adoperatevi cominciate a correre cercate
di essere più carichi possibili mettete
più chilometri possibili nel vostro
motore e sappiate che più camminerete e
più cose belle
vi capiteranno e magari ti capiterà
anche qualche buca e magari vi capiterà
anche qualche piccolo incidente di
percorso ma sappiate che a proposito di
incidenti sì a proposito incidenti c'è
un video un video che vorrei mostrarvi
un video che vede come protagonista un
atleta americano che ha partecipato alle
olimpiadi di barcellona
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ecco derek raymond ha fatto un gesto
praticamente inutile a cosa serviva
alzarsi supplicante arrivare al
traguardo con tanti minuti di ritardo
sui vincitori
era un gesto inutile apparentemente
inutile però perché con questo gesto lui
ha creato una delle pagine più belle
della storia dello sport mondiale
e lui oggi è famoso il suo nome è più
conosciuto di coloro che hanno vinto di
quello che sono arrivati sul sul podio e
delle multinazionali hanno scelto lui
come testimonial come se fosse stato il
vincitore
allora vedete io sono convinto di una
cosa non conosco di persona
derek redmond non sono sicuro che lui
amava fortemente il suo lavoro
sono sicuro che lui era una persona che
amava fare le cose per bene
sono sicuro che lui amava le sfide della
vita e sono sicuro anche che davanti
alle difficoltà lui ha capito che non
bisogna scoraggiarsi mai che bisogna
andare avanti nonostante tutto
e se proprio qualcosa dovesse sembrare
veramente difficile
lui sa che può urlare non ci ferma
nessuno
grazie
grazie di cuore
grazie a tutti